welcome back
um we're gonna have an R session now
this time on model selection so uh we've
got a script ready
um we're going to look at uh using
validation sets cross validation for
selecting the tuning parameters in in
stepwise regression lassu Ridge
regression and the like this will be
broken up into a few sessions and we're
going to do something a little different
this time in the past I've just shown
you in our script that we've used in
rstudio where we click through the
commands well this time we're going to
do it in a also in our studio but using
something called markdown mode and what
that is is it's a way of merging text
with our code and at the end of the day
you can produce a document in this case
a HTML document or a web page and as
you'll see it's just about as easy to do
as as using the script and and it just
becomes much much more useful especially
for making demonstrations
so let's see how this works
okay so here's our markdown
script it's the beginning of it and
you'll see it's got actual just text
written in the beginning that says this
is an r dot markdown document and and
it's got model selection at the top and
it's underlined with the double with
equal signs and there's a few
conventions in markdown I'll just click
this help pane over here and you see the
very simple instructions on how to
structure markdown on the right so it's
very easy to learn
and the r code actually sits in chunks
and so here's a chunk over here and we
just execute code in the chunks just
like we did before notice the chunks
begin with this
um
backslip back quote back back quote and
then R it's a little incantation which
you can invoke by using a keystroke
and we execute the commands just as
before so here we are we go Library uh
hit islr and that we're going to use the
hitters database which is a baseball
database which has a recording of a
whole lot of statistics for different
baseball players and including
a response variable salary which we're
going to use as the target for a
regression model and so there we see
celery we notice it's got a bunch of
missing values 59 missing values which
is going to be a little unpleasant for
us so we're going to do something about
that but just for the moment look at the
summary and you can see all the names of
the variables these are statistics that
have been collected during the you know
baseball season
and we're going to try and use these
statistics to predict the salary of the
the player
so
missing values are
the various ways of dealing with him
we're going to take the easy way out
here and we're going to eliminate any
Row in the data frame that's got a
missing value in it and there's a nice
function called na.mit that does that
for you and we run n a DOT Emit and that
will produce a new data frame which we
just overwrite on hitters here and it
won't have any missing values it'll have
less rows of course
and then we can just check if there's
any Nas in in this new data frame
hitters and here we use our width
function again because it's kind of cute
so with data frame hitters look at the
sum of any well is n a are there any n
a's in the variable salary and when we
do that we get zero which is what we
expected okay
all right so the first thing we're going
to do is we're going to see how to do
best subset regression so if you recall
from the from the lectures best subset
regression looks through all possible
regression models of all different
subset sizes and looks for the best of
each size and so produces a sequence of
models which is the best subset for each
particular size
okay and that sounds like a lot of work
but luckily we've got a library called
leaps that'll do that for us
and there's a function in leaps called
reg subsets that'll do that will do the
best subset modeling for us and so yeah
we we assigned to regfit.fool
um this rig subsets with celery as a
response it takes a formula and the data
is hitters
and it's amazingly fast
um we've got
you know we've got over 200 baseball
players here and it did all subsets and
we got 19 variables and it did all
subsets regression in no time at all
and if we do a summary we get a kind of
printout of that summarizes the best
subset models and what it does is
for each subset size for so for example
subset size 1 it Show puts a star next
to the variable that's in the best
subset of size one so that's crbi
and then the best subset of size 2 of
course is going to be two with stars
and three and so on and uh
for the beginning it looks like these
subsets are nested but they don't have
to be nested and if you study this this
output you'll see that at some point
they're not nested
um and
so that's one way of looking at our base
subset
um
by default it only goes up to subsets of
size eight maybe that's why it was so
fast but we got 19 variables so we're
going to actually go all the way and get
best subsets all the way up to size 19.
so we'll run that one well that was just
as fast it's instantaneous and if we do
the summary of that
um well we didn't print it out but uh we
ran the summary and
real uh
and let me look at the
bigger pardon it names in the summary
and the summary you know we've just now
printed the summary but um this tells
you what's on the Sabri and it has
various things
like for each of the models the best
subset models it has the r squared the
residual sum of squared the the adjusted
um r squared the CP statistic the Bic
statistic and a few other things all the
things that
um we're going to use to help us select
um the particular model
so happily there's a plot method for
for
um
well actually there's not we're going to
plot the CP component of reg summary
we'll just make our own plot there it is
and remember CP is a estimate of
prediction error and here it's plotted
we plotted it against the number of
variables and the CP statistic and the
idea is to pick a model with the lowest
CP
well in this case it looks like
the model with 10 variables is is the
smallest and we can
just use the function which dotman
to identify the smallest
um
index of the smallest element of the CP
component
and let's just annotate our plot by
indicating the point that we've chosen
the best subset model there we used
points to color the point red the one
that's going to be the chosen model
so that's pretty straightforward using
CP to do best subset selection using the
function rig subsets
um
there is a plot method for the reg
subsets object it wasn't the one I was
that we just produced
so let's use it
and it's a it's like a pattern picture
and at first you have to figure out how
to interpret this plot what it shows is
on this axis here is the CP statistic
small is good so this is the smallest CP
this will have corresponded to our model
of size 10 and then you see CP getting
worse and worse and then for each value
of CP or each unique value of CP
it black squares are ones indicating
that variables in and white squares or
the variables are out
okay and so it's an interesting picture
so what you notice is near the bottom of
the CPS the models are reasonably stable
like this whole band stays the same
there's a little bit of fluctuation over
here
what you also notice is that as we
should expect from that previous plot
that bad CPS corresponded to models that
had all the variables in all ones that
had hardly any variables in and so you
know you get used to interpreting this
plot and it's it's you know it sort of
gives a quick summary of all the models
as opposed to just seeing the CP
statistics
and now having chosen model 10 there's a
coefficient method for for egg subsets
and we ask it for the coefficients for
model
Chorus for the model indexed 10 and we
get a coefficient vector
and it's gives you the coefficients of
those variables that those 10 variables
that are in the model
and there they are
okay well so that's the end of the first
little session we'll we'll carry on with
subsequent sessions using different
methods for model selection
before we leave I want to show you how
you actually get a nice
summary the HTML file of everything that
we've done so far so you'll notice at
the top here there's a command knit HTML
so we're going to issue that
and
it shows us it's this is the web page
that shows us everything
that we've done but it's formatted
nicely so we get all our commands we get
headings the model selection we get our
commands the text is nicely formatted
and we also get the output the r output
is commented with with two hashes on the
side and then any graphic that we
any graphic that we produced also
appears in this plot so that's a very
nice way of retaining everything that
you've done
um in in our session